this is another thing i had to i had to
learn
sometimes you could be chasing some [ __ ]
that you already got mm-hmm and i'm
explaining this to you i was ordering my
plaques and [ __ ] right and
i was ordering like
a young money gold album [ __ ] i am
not a human being album because i was on
two records on there and there's
platinum all right
get my plaque but i never really paid
attention to this type of [ __ ] so i
would go to producers houses and they'd
be like yo mills you
i would go to an engineer house and he
would be engineered on an album and he
would have a plaque and i wouldn't but
i'm on it and they were like yo order so
now i'm ordering my plaques billboard
plaques young money debuted at number
one hit number one the second album
debuted here soulless so this one was
numb so i'm like now i'm ordering all
these these plaques these young money
plaques
so i'm like
you know i'll be on my geek [ __ ]
sometimes man
let me google
myself on billboard right
you see
so i was like damn i i i google myself
look up the date back search and all
that [ __ ]
and i'm like damn i was on the billboard
charts when i was still living in my
mom's crib
i was on the billboard charts before i
was on the billboard charts with young
money but i just never knew
so i started ordering all them shits
order no no no order who
all the streets melting featuring swiss
beats i don't give a [ __ ] if it's number
20 if it peaked at 28
and it hit 43 or if it peaked that
number 12 and it was it dropped down to
80 something
it was there
so you need to see that every day so you
can know that's not something you need
to keep chasing
chase some other [ __ ] right wake up
every day roll you up
look at that time where you was in the
hot 100 and you peaked at number 23 in
2004.